Jenkins can you explain something for me  yes sir can you explain why morbius  flopped but people are seeing this  minions [ __ ] in droves they're  dressed up at suits it's it's a little  uh it's a little extreme well it's just  become a meme you know the grandmas are  saying it sincerely and the Zoomers are  seeing it ironically morbius was the  biggest meme in America for months okay  we put it in theaters the second time  and nobody shows up in their fancy  little outfits it isn't fair we're doing  everything we can to cynically  capitalize on the morbius meme and  nothing works well I think that's what  makes it so funny then what do we do  we could release it a third time let's  release it a third time